[Musique]
mon dieu protège papa et brigitte
patrick et bernadette et même andrew
protège wilbert et tous les chevaux fois
la finale
mais nation est à son comble pour cet
événement de l'année 34 à caen ce n'est
plus important totalité
[Musique]
tu prête pas part je veux aller en
groupe
je veux être meilleur bonjour je suis
michel pech je suis choqué et libre pour
un travail de cavaliers de piste
j'attends dehors si vous avez besoin de
moi il me faut plus qu'un manager une
femme jockey pas si mal que ça fait quoi
après la course
champagne
prince of rain dance avec licha est en
route pour la course
une fille d'un grand jamais elle
melbourne cup retourne dans ton bled
[Musique]
j'ai déjà perdu ma femme est une vie
que se passera-t-il c'est humain
il faut que je monte ce cheval une autre
blessure à la tête pourrait être fatal
j'ai pourrait remonter quand c'est une
course très périlleuse il faut beaucoup
de courage pensé que c'était une
question de force
il s'agit de bien plus important que ça
[Musique]
j'ai une chance je sais que ce cheval en
live nation est à son comble pour cet
événement de la belgique
[Musique]
et c'est exister l'ex qui remonte
légèrement
[Musique]
la seule chose qui compte ce sont les
chances que tu vas te donner
[Musique]